what you're about to hear may shock you
and go against everything you've ever
been told about your health and how to
get well government corporations and
doctors share a medical monopoly making
billions of dollars with the current
model of drugs and surgery while
aggressively opposing every other form
of treatment the United States alone
spends over three trillion dollars a
year on health care more than every
other nation on earth combined yet
according to its own Center for Disease
Control the overall health of its
citizens is worse than 90 other
countries why is it so hard to admit the
most expensive surgeries and finest
dangerous drugs for chronic illness
simply do not work modern medicine is
invaluable for infectious disease and
emergency care but aren't we just
fooling ourselves as we race for the
Cure and dump water on our heads if we
think massive organizations are going to
cure themselves right out of the
billions of dollars they raise every
year even if they were looking in the
right place the real solution to the
world's healthcare crisis has already
been discovered it lies within the
body's own ability to heal itself and
essential nutrients missing from our
food for years is the key to unlocking
the power that is already within us if
you suffer with diabetes heart disease
arthritis high blood pressure multiple
sclerosis cystic fibrosis muscular
dystrophy ALS Alzheimer's or any other
chronic illness you can name you'll want
to hear what dr. Joel Wallach has to say
dr. Wallach veterinarian pathologist and
physician is the author of the most
popular health lecture in history dead
doctors don't lie as a veterinarian he's
seen the elimination of over 900
different diseases and birth defects in
the animal industry as a physician he's
proving the same thing can be done for
humans his discoveries have shown that
disease is not genetic and he's had to
sue the FDA eight times for the right to
make certain health claims that are true
with 50 years of research and experience
25,000 autopsies and 10 million blood
chemistry's dr. Wallach is in a unique
position to reveal exactly what's needed
to get and stay well your body is the
miracle scrape your knee and it heals
all by itself address the nutritional
deficiencies that cause chronic disease
and the body can fix that too with the
right nutritional supplementation
millions are getting their health back
as they come to find out healing is easy
I'm dr. Peter Glidden I'm a licensed
naturopathic physician I have 25 years
of clinical experience helping people to
recover their health with science-based
clinically verified alternatives to
drugs and surgery and I'm here with a
close personal friend of mine my mentor
and my colleague dr. Joel Wallach we're
going to be talking today about dr.
Wallach groundbreaking medical nutrition
information a very famous lecture dead
doctors don't lie and an
autobiographical book of the same title
dr. Wallach it's always a pleasure being
with you welcome aboard
thank you dr. Glidden appreciate been
with you so what makes your view of
medicine different from anybody else's
just by way of introduction for those
who don't know me the things that makes
me different is I do have a degree in
agriculture and a veterinarian compared
pathologists and a HP ethic physician
for what
thirty six years and it's a different
thing to be a physician and I learned
this of course in veterinary medicine
growing up in the farm if a veterinarian
would come out to the farm and he say
look your bull here has arthritis in
both his hips cost 160 thousand dollars
for double hip replacement BAM he'd hear
the shot go off as a farmer shootable
but it's a farmer would have the
veterinarian tell him look your bull has
arthritis that's why he can't breed the
cows but for a few pennies here I can
regrow the cartilage regrow his hips and
he'll be as good as new in 90 days then
that bull has a new lease on life right
farmers happy saves a lot of money and
he'll invite the veterinarian back if we
use the human type of system for
healthcare in livestock it would be so
expensive that a dozen eggs would cost
you $250 a pound of hamburger question
500 bucks just to pay for the healthcare
so we invented a system in the livestock
industry of prevention this is how we
deal with it mostly we can reverse
diseases with nutrition but still a
little more you
offensive than actually preventing
disease so we work on a herd base so we
treat herds as opposed as treating
individuals and as a result we've wiped
out type 2 diabetes Parkinson's ease
cancer MS heart disease of all kinds
liver disease fibromyalgia birth defects
like cleft palates things like the
cerebral palsy early births or they have
you know you have these preemies to
require two or three months in
incubators ki imagine a farmer having to
put a 30% of his calves every spring and
an incubator for three months before he
can put them in the feedlot your
hamburgers would cost 500 bucks right
about and so we learned how to deal with
all this and always fascinated me as a
kid why we did all that for animals and
nobody's doing the same thing for people
and I didn't pursue it because I was so
busy with my animal stuff the Marlon
Perkins and saving the white rhino and
the elephants and Africa and I was
forced
of course into treating humans when I
was fired for discovering the first
non-human case of cystic fibrosis and
rhesus monkeys when you have that kind
of information I couldn't bring myself
to feel good about going and doing
something else if you have the
information you can save millions of
kids I had to pursue that that's how I
got into human medicine
she was nine months when she had her
first seizure we call the ambulance
and they rushed her into the emergency
room her brain looked perfect everything
was good
so we went a few months without any
seizures at all and then she had one
about three months after that and they
just kept getting more frequent and
frequent as the time went by to the
point where she was having four to six
seizures in one day so she got stronger
and stronger medications as things went
to the point where she got on a
medication that was considered a
biohazard where I had to wear gloves to
administer and I thought if I can't even
touch this why is it going to go into my
brand-new baby into her system so I
couldn't do it it broke my heart so I
just gave it to her one time and she was
a walking zombie she just wouldn't talk
wouldn't play she was just not normal at
all so I thought you know we'll deal
with the seizures I just want her to be
happy we were introduced to dr. Wallach
snoot Rishon we didn't think it would
work because we thought all these
medications that the doctors gave us
didn't work so this is not going to work
we gave it to her that same night and we
went the whole night without having any
seizures and we woke up and gave her
some more of it that whole day she
didn't have a seizure at all and so now
it's been a year and some months
of her not having any seizures at all
I'm not in fear constantly thinking that
oh she's going to go into a seizure
being on the medication and still having
them and then being on the nutrition
overnight not having any seizures for a
year and a half is just amazing in the
field of nature Pathak medicine the
nature Pathak physicians are really the
only licensed and regulated physicians
in the world who have any training any
experience and quite frankly any eye
towards the relationship between
nutrition and disease and health now you
have been published over thirty times
seventy five seventy five times you have
a book in the Smithsonian Institution
which was the result of a twenty five
million dollar federally funded project
that you were in charge of your
experience with pragmatic old-fashioned
boots-on-the-ground nutritional research
is is equaled by nobody in the world
right now and then you bring to the
table your experience as a naturopathic
physician actually treating real
patients in real time with medical
nutrition interventions what types of
results are you seeing in real people
with real disease with medical nutrition
well I've been doing this for 36 years
now and my patients affectionately say I
treat them like dogs but they get better
okay because I hang my my veterinary
degree on the wall next to my nature
pathogen green the veterinary ones twice
as big so they see so they say treat
them like dogs but they do get better
for instance what I've learned here in
36 years is that I can make a church
family type 2 diabetes 3 and 2 or 3
months they're getting their legs
amputated they're going blind they're
gaining weight they're having all these
complications cardiovascular disease all
the stuff that goes along with chronic
type 2 diabetes and I can prevent
reverse all that you know dialysis I get
people off at Dallas Edith's been on
Dallas a-- for 73 years in two weeks
time they're urinating for the first
time and in two months time they're off
analysis and so these are the sort of
things i see just very
recently we have a community of Latinos
in North LA in just the last three
months
we were able to get 400 diabetics off
their medicine the combination of pills
and insulin to where they're now X AB
etics in just a couple of months because
100 people 400 people because in reality
type 2 diabetes and all chronic diseases
as Linus Pauling stated years ago you
can trace every chronic disease back to
a mineral deficiency a nutrient
deficiency of some sort and conventional
medical doctors bless their hearts have
no training no experience quite frankly
no appreciation for medical nutrition so
from our point of view chronic diseases
are not genetically don't have a bad
gene it's not the aging process
if you're having trouble metabolizing
blood sugar it's because your body has
run out of the raw materials it needs to
process blood sugar if your bones and
joints start to go south it's because
your body has run out of the raw
materials it needs to keep that part of
the body healthy right correct now this
is why we're able to take 400 people and
out of 400 people with type 2 diabetes
they've had eight 10 12 15 20 30 years
they have one family where the mother
and father had diabetes type 2 obese for
30 years the son had it for 12 years all
three of them in two months time our
diabetes rate and then the young fellow
actually lost 78 pounds on top of that
and so the reason is as you point out
the the type 2 diabetes is not
genetically transmitted as doctors have
you believe it's a simple mineral
deficiency we've known it for 70 years
in the animal industry we just put these
minerals in there a little alfalfa
pellets we give to horses and sheep and
pigs and guinea pigs and rats and
chickens and dogs and they don't get the
disease and so again I use the same
principles that we use in the veterinary
industry to prevent reverse these
diseases and it always works it always
works there's only two reasons why
proper supplementation will not prevent
reverse diseases number one is you're
under dosing because inventor name
everything by body weight and you
and they do everything by age well I
know twelve-year-old kids are 300 pounds
I know nine-year-old people who are 70
pounds and so you can't go by age you
got to go by body weight they may be
doing all the correct stuff but they're
under dosing and then of course the
other reason is they're not absorbing
and there's many reasons why people
don't absorb but minerals for instance
you could take all the iron supplements
you want but if you don't have enough
acid in your stomach you're not gonna be
able to absorb the iron you can take all
the b12 you want but if you don't have
any ass in your stomach you're not be
able to absorb b12 you can eat all the
great and high-quality protein you want
but if you don't have an ass in your
stomach you're not going to be able to
break down proteins and amino acids
let's say you have all that you have
your digested food going down in your
intestinal tracts and it's coming out in
the toilet just like it was when it left
your stomach you know absorbing it
well what would cause that in gluten
intolerance asthma is a secondary
nutritional deficiency a gluten
intolerance that's a very common disease
eczema dermatitis things like rosacea in
the face these things are all an
psoriasis these are all caused second
early is the nutritional deficiencies -
gluten intolerance because you can't
absorb the nutrients that would prevent
these or reverse it and then there is
celiac disease and diverticulitis and
appendicitis and herbal syndrome
inflammatory bowel syndrome colitis
Tulsa colitis and Crohn's disease well
doctors say these things are all
autoimmune diseases that went touch her
intestines out but they're all caused by
directly by gluten intolerance so the
diseases of gluten in towns around for
5,000 years they were recorded by the
Egyptian physicians in a role papyri
5000 years ago but modern medicine never
related these diseases to a gluten
intolerance right they just said they're
autoimmune or genetic right and that's
where they failed
actually I was a photographer for Walt
Disney in Orlando Florida and one day I
just was not feeling well and went to
the infirmary
they rushed me to the hospital they were
able to do a triple bypass at the same
time I had Bell's palsy sleep apnea
type-2 diabetes high blood pressure high
cholesterol I'm not expected to live
very long and so my son moved me to Utah
was going to church and I had a husband
and wife that came up to me said we can
help you if you'll just take these we'll
give them to if you promise you'll take
them then I said okay I'm willing to try
anything and within three weeks my
type-2 diabetes was reversed dr. Wallach
he's my man he is my doctor I was on
about 28 pharmaceuticals and after 90
days the only thing I was taking was a
81 milligram baby aspirin
[Music]
there's Alzheimers ease which is a
physician cause disease 43 years ago
alzheimers disease didn't exist right
today it's number four killer of annals
or it goes from zero forty three years
ago to the number four killer of adults
over the age of 65 because of the way
doctors treated other diseases they want
you to believe of course and that's
another story but don't you believe that
cardiovascular disease of all kinds is
caused by elevated blood cholesterol and
they do everything they can to lower
cholesterol that's their goal listed
lower cholesterol and they think they're
gonna help cardiovascular disease in
fact there's not a single disease caused
by elevated blood cholesterol there's
many many diseases caused by
deficiencies of cholesterol including
Al's heresies and that's why it's
getting worse and worse and worse than
the age group of people without some
disease now getting lower and lower and
lower and of course this is caused by a
lack of cholesterol which makes up 75%
of the human brain in the form of myelin
the insulation children makes up 75% of
the human brain and this myelin is 100%
cholesterol so you go to a closer
restricted diet take
cholesterol-lowering drugs you get low
tea low testosterone erectile
dysfunction because you can't make
enough testosterone which is 95 percent
cholesterol right and then you wind up
with no replacement of myelin which
tends to go away like all living things
have replenish it well if you don't have
enough cholesterol replenish your myelin
you get alzheimerís disease and so I
began to give people 6 8 10 12 25 eggs a
day poached eggs to rebuild the myelin
in the brain give them all 90 essential
nutrients and as some of my very famous
cases and stories one of my first ones
with Allison disease was out of North
Carolina he'd been diagnosed by very
credible neurological clinics I was
having Aylmer disease as man sells her
disease and his sister didn't want to
believe that so she took him to various
neurological clinics all over North
Carolina and other places and they all
agreed and eventually he got to the
point where he had to be put in the
hospice
and a mutual friend introduced us and I
said I can help him but he's gonna
require all of these nutrients of 90
essential nutrients he needs 12 eggs
twice a day and he saw this isn't this
and of course the nursing home people
weren't gonna do that so she was willing
to take off a six months leave of
absence from her job to grind all this
stuff and put it through his g-tube in
the hospice and she did it well and a
week's time
Raymond gets up gets dressed walks out
perfectly normal
seven days seven days he'd been in going
downhill was diagnosis by multiples of
neurological clinics very well-respected
neurologic clinics medical doctors all
saying he had terminal Allison disease
and he was in fact terminal and in just
a week on this program he got up got
dressed and walked out and that's
because he did not have Allison disease
he had Korsakoff syndrome I kind of felt
that from the story and I gave him
28,000 times the minimum daily
requirement that one vitamin and so I
used a big hammer because he only had
weeks to live so I had to use a bigger
hammer than just give him the minimum
doses and by golly thanks to the good
Lord he got up walked out perfectly
normal well it started about three and a
half years ago I just moved back on from
a bad relationship and I just going
through a hard time Mia introduced me to
dr. Wallach protocol and I honestly was
just like sure everyone needs a little
bit of nutrition little did I know that
soon after started just feeling better
about life in general I don't know I
felt just happier that's getting the
nutrition I needed so I stopped eating
all these crappy foods I was eating and
sugar cravings and things I had more
energy so I naturally just started
losing weight without trying and I mean
it happened quick I lost 40 pounds in a
matter of three or four months without
trying so it was pretty amazing and and
I had 30 to 40 pounds to lose it has
started me on a new path of nutrition
when your body is giving the nutrients
it needs and it's being fed and and
you're given the right tools and can do
amazing things I owe it to the dr.
Wallach protocol I really do I actually
was eight years ago diagnosed with
Huntington's disease which is like three
or four it's the worst disease to have
because there's no cure it's ms MD
Parkinson's and Korea it eats my brain a
little every day and there was no
medication at all for me when I first
got it they said there's nothing for you
and my mother died of it so it was dying
afraid when I got it but and I was so
sad it takes everything away your
communication how you think everything
you do I used to teach I used to do five
different things and I went from cooking
everything and doing everything to not
being able to cook or take care of
myself and I was going to go to a sister
living where they you know totally take
care of us as honey tons and girls saw
me and said we have something for you
and you've got to try it for three
months and then I so I said okay I'll
try and I'll try anything because there
was nothing out there from
at all within weeks I could tell the
difference in my writing and what I was
doing opening bottles like right now I
can open a water bottle I had no clue of
where I would be today compared to
really how bad I was as I was going to a
home where they take care of you
completely to me being able to live
alone and do my own laundry and cook and
everything right now dr. Aulick I'm
amazed I want to cry I'm teaching
everything cool
you